this right here is the Leia loompad 2
the world's first tablet that literally
uses AI to create an endless supply of
3D content yes I said 3D and I know what
you're thinking there's no way this
looks good but I've been using it for a
bit and it actually replicates the kind
of 3D experience that you get in a movie
theater from the comfort of your home or
anywhere you go now unfortunately just
like a 3D movie you actually have to see
it in person with your own two eyes to
get the real 3D experience but in this
video I'll do my best to explain how it
works what you can do with it including
how you can watch any YouTube video in
3D and I'll walk you through all the
apps it comes with to make really good
use of the integrated 3D technology but
before that I want to quickly go through
some of the specs not only is the
display 3D but you actually get dual
light field cameras on both the front
front and the back so you can take
photos and record video and see them in
3D you can even use their chat app to do
a 3D video call with someone else which
is actually really impressive it comes
with a 12.4 inch 2560 by 1600 resolution
display which uses Leia's third gen
proprietary DLB 3D technology which is a
thin nanotech layer that sits beneath
that is screen so you don't need any
glasses at all it also comes with
Flagship specs so a Snapdragon 888 chip
Android 12 8 gigs of RAM 128 gigs of
storage Dolby Atmos speakers and even an
SD card slot you've got speaker grills
on the sides yes quad speakers you have
pins on the bottom for cases and stands
and of course you get a USBC Port now
getting into how this works let's open
up the Leia player app which is packed
with photos and 3D videos as well so
let's open this right right here you
guys can see from the top cam
unfortunately you probably can't see the
3D in action but oh my goodness this
really does work insanely well this is
like going to a 3D movie theater wow
that's good literally the faces are up
close and everything has depth that is
amazing there you go I just brought up
the brightness oh my goodness this is
literally it's working insanely well now
within this app and basically any other
app you can easily just hit the 2D
button there you go you're back to a
regular basic tablet experience or when
you switch to 3D it works incredibly
well because it separates the different
layers of depth and then pops them out
for your 3D experience but then even
better it actually uses phase tracking
with the cameras so that when you adjust
the angle of the iPad it actually moves
around using the face tracking now they
also have their Leia flicks app where
you can rent actual 3D Hollywood movies
like you can see right here just click
on one there you go rent it two dollars
and you get a full movie theater 3D
experience which is awesome but the main
thing I want to show you is the Leia
Tube app which you can go into and watch
a bunch of different videos we have ones
from Vimeo but the coolest things that
you could actually convert YouTube
videos into 3D videos and I'll show you
how to do it right now just go into the
YouTube app then find a video like let's
say our own 13 Pro Max honest review you
just click share click more and then
click on Leia tube it's gonna open it up
and look at this it's automatically
converting a 2d video into 3D and just
like that a few seconds later check this
out it is already done 3D video is done
and oh my goodness
I can't believe it the 3D is working
guys oh my goodness how does it know
how does the AI do this okay even even
the a-roll oh my goodness this is
absolutely insane wow now sometimes it
does look like the 3d effect can kind of
get glitched out a little bit but they
have the slider where you can turn down
the effect which solves that issue and I
like it like this where I still see the
3D the glitches go away and it's a
really nice experience next up they have
their Leia cam app which you can open up
and take 3D photos and videos so I don't
know if you guys can see this on the top
cam but there you go just take a photo
of the iPhone right there and it
actually shows you this window at the
top where you can see kind of the 3D
depth data now going back to the phone
there you go you can see we have a 3D
iPhone image and even better I took this
3D
selfie and I legit actually pop out this
is incredible and then I definitely want
to show you guys Leia dream check this
out this actually uses stable diffusion
to create AI generated art from any
prompt that you put in so let's say
we'll go to the diffusion model let's do
uh diffusion 2.1 right there we've set
it up let's give us I don't know just
one image for now change the width let's
just do some crazy like human with a cat
head click the dream button let's see
what pops up whoa there you go we just
got this really really weird thing we
had this human and then a cat in front
of it but check this out we actually
have the 3D model that we can click into
there you go you can see the 3D depths
which the 2D 3D Focus adjust that whoa
okay even animate it okay this is crazy
let's try man with bear head all right
look at that that is so crazy what in
the world whoa okay this 3d effect is
wow much more pronounced this is so
weird now they also have the Leia pix
app and leopix converter which lets you
convert your own images into 3D and
share them like we got Pikachu right
here we have this really cool kind of
astronaut wow that's that's really
really cool they're just kind of
floating there and look we got E.T right
here and that actually works insanely
well it almost like feels like he's in
the device now there's also the Leia
viewer you could actually come up here
and open up one of these 3D models like
actual 3D models and you could look at
them in 3D oh my goodness this works so
incredibly well wow oh my oh that feels
weird it feels like it's right here but
it's not and wow look I can even zoom in
got a little rabbit there oh that is
this is so wow oh like my brain it can't
even comprehend how my fingers are not
going into it okay that is realistic now
there's also the Leia frame app which
basically turns the tablet into kind of
like an art picture frame but with 3D it
Cycles through the photos and wow that
is kind of cool it kind of gets rid of
everything else and just plays a
slideshow which you could show people a
bunch of 3D photos now they also have
the game cyber cup
so as you can see it's working 3D let's
take a look this seems to be I think
it's actually a demo so this is a game
demo kind of showing what it would look
like
this is very simple hey where'd that guy
go oh there's a guy boom it's like
cyberpunk but cyber cop
boom and Bam well this is definitely
working in 3D that's for sure and there
you go
um that's it okay well demo is a demo
there's also the dungeon find the key
whoa this looks kind of crazy oh there's
a bad guy and he's dead oh one hit one
hitter quitter man okay this is crazy
like the 3DS like when you move it
around like oh look at oh look
I could see it from like a whole
different 3D angle this looks insane now
why can't I kill this guys do I just run
away
good run oh there's a boss
come on oh that was quick he's dead yeah
I'm gonna run guys
oh yeah this guy's got a trash can on
his head trash can helmet oh there you
go and they died
and I won and then of course finally
they have the Leia app store where you
can go in you could download a bunch of
different 3D apps that people have you
can download different 3D games as well
so that's their App Store now the
awesome thing about all of this is that
they basically created their own 3D app
ecosystem so that you could have endless
amounts of 3D content especially since
you can turn any YouTube video into a 3D
video and you don't even need to wear
glasses or anything else it just works
now I know some of you guys are gonna
say that this is a gimmick no one's
actually gonna use this but after
watching this for a bit I'm actually
impressed how it looks like a 3D movie
in the theaters it actually works and it
looks great and in any case you could
also just click the 3D button and then
switch to 2D and use it like a regular
tablet but the big idea here is why not
have both so you guys let me know what
you think about this this 3D tablet the
loom Pad 2 down below and I'm gonna have
links where you can order it in the
description and pin comment below as
well so hopefully you enjoy this review
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
foreign